son avocat thomas b nager ton direct
avec nous bonsoir et merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation sur arte
france comment votre client at il a
accueilli cette plante du conseil de
l'ordre des médecins
et bien elle a été accueillie avec
beaucoup de stupéfaction quand même mais
elle est accueillie par le professeur
theron dans un contexte où il y avait eu
la semaine dernière la décision de
l'ap-hp de suspendre sa sa chefferie de
service et donc conserver rome est en
train de vie lui dire un moment où
toutes les institutions sont dans des
décisions contre et forcément il se pose
des questions sur le fait que sur la
coordination ces attaques
la tht le conseil national de l'ordre
des médecins est bon donc c'est on sent
vraiment qu'il y a coordination des
attaques à smoke ondes et il n'y a
absolument rien de fortuit là dedans
donc il ne prend comme un mec avec eux
ou deux situations en s'interrogeant
quand même sur 7 comme si est ce que
justement pour qu'on comprenne bien
comment ce qu'elle a émergé cette plante
et sur quoi s'appuient aujourd'hui
l'ordre des médecins qu'est-ce qui lé
héros que ce qui est reproché
précisément à votre client tout d'abord
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
les éléments de la plainte
l'ordre national des médecins on ne les
connaît pas encore cela va suivre une
procédure très précise c'est à dire que
j'ai commencé
c'est comme conseil national de samedi a
transmis la classe à la chambre
disciplinaire
la chambre disciplinaire ensuite
transmettre cette plainte au professeur
peron et là on prendra connaissance très
précisément des éléments des charges qui
sont portées contre lui mais pour
l'instant tout ce que je sais concernant
cette plainte du conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins
on ne le sait que par la presse donc on
a pas plus d'éléments et il
très difficile du coup de répondre
précisément sur chaque griefs
mais ce que l'on sait ce que l'on peut
dire dès à présent c'est que les
plaintes ordinale ce sont des plaintes
qui concerne des manquements au code de
déontologie
le code de déontologie médicale donc ce
que l'on peut supposer c'est que cette
plainte vise le professeur carole pour
des manquements au code de déontologie
donc il faudrait avoir justement est ce
qu'il ya des règles déontologiques qui
régissent la prise de parole de
professionnels renommés de la santé
alors tout à fait il y à des règles
déontologiques
concernant la prise de parole elles sont
à la fois elles sont très largement être
très très fort alors déjà entre deux
entre deux praticiens entre des
professionnels la prise de parole il est
prévu que les professionnels ne doivent
pas médire les uns des autres
donc ça c'est la première chose en
l'espèce le professeur carole mhamedi
d'aucun deux de ses confrères donc le
procès ron a toujours tenu des propos
qui qui concernaient des commentaires
sur la crise sanitaire concernant
qu'ovide de propos concernant une itt
roque situées en chine mais il n'a
jamais dit l'un de ses confrères
contrairement à l'or quand il explique
que les consultations madame ducobu 19
notamment représente une nouvelle
financière pour les médecins que les
patients en réanimation constituent eux
un jackpot pour les autorités sanitaires
est ce que là ils sortent des clous
tout d'abord si tu ne peux pas vous
remarquerez que dans ses remarques
il n'y a aucune remarque aucune critique
par rapport à un confrère très précis
très précisément alors que ce que l'on
peut dire c'est que depuis des semaines
est là depuis certains jours il y à un
véritable machine à l'encontre des roms
étaient de très nombreux médecins vont
dire des choses insensées haine à son
encontre vont l'insulté sur les plateaux
télé vont harceler même sur twitter et
vous avez de très nombreux médecins qui
vont s'en prendre directement aux
professeurs
eron admin m et ces médecins là ils ne
sont inquiétés par le conseil de l'ordre
déjà il convient de le soulever c'est
que en ce qui concerne le respect des
règles de confraternité le château
palmer dire d'un autre passion d'un
autre homme simple on aurait le droit
tous les médecins de france aurait le
droit d'insulter le professeur des roms
alors que lui il n'a insulté personne
il a tenu des propos qui sont contestés
dans la véracité est contesté par le
conseil national de l'ordre des médecins
mais justement la véracité des propos
tenus par le professeur et ron devra
être pourquoi pas débattu par le conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins en tout
état de cause par la chambre devant la
chambre disciplinaire mais il ya un
principe fondamental quoi qu'il en soit
c'est celui de la liberté d'expression
la liberté d'expression des
universitaires des professeurs héros
vous avez est ce que vous direz que
c'est là finalement une première étape
vers un cadrage des prises de parole
dans les médias parce qu'on a entendu et
on continue d'entendre beaucoup de
médecins de spécialistes défendre des
idées de toutes sortes
d'ailleurs ce que vous avez le sentiment
qu'avec une telle plainte on se dirige
finalement vers une seule parole
officiel et autorisé dans les médias
alors concrètement c'est ce que l'on
peut que c'est ce que l'on peut penser d
une part une seule parole officielle on
a vu ce que cela pouvait donner
justement pas pour alexis claudine et on
constate que tous les propos qui ont pu
être tenus par le professeur à péronne
même temps le prohon concernant hydroxy
clan qui ne leur ont valu des torrents
de d'insultés et de critiques de la part
des institutions officielles des
différents conseils de l'ordre que ce
soit départementaux ou du conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins
donc oui on peut parler d'une parole
officielle est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le conseil national de l'ordre
des médecins au mois d'avril a publié un
communiqué de presse
et donc ce communiqué de presse il dit
et il ne faudrait pas que dire mais ils
menaçaient tous les médecins de france
qui a souhaité soignés des malades du
covan
il est menacé de suspension et de
sanctions et dont on voit que mois
d'avril le conseil de l'ordre des
médecins à intimider tous les médecins
de france pour qu'ils ne fassent rien
dans le cadre d'une crise sanitaire
cette parole du conseil national lors
des naissains fait l'objet d'une plainte
que j'ai déposée
watchmen justement parce qu'on compte
pénal sanctionne l'intimidation des
médecins qui s'abstiennent prescrire des
actes de leurs fonctions ce que je
retiens tout dernier mot parce que
malheureusement le temps nous manque
concernant les risques qu'encourent
votre client et la suite juridique aussi
que vous allez mener alors les risques
d'actes et mon client tout de suite il a
été démis de ses fonctions de chef de
service depuis la semaine dernière
donc la baie hp a pris à son encontre
une sanction
et cette décision de l'ap hp va faire
l'objet d'un recours devant un tribunal
administratif de paris qui va être
déposée sous 48 heures donc déjà il y à
une sanction qui a été prise à
l'encontre du professeur peron par la
phb
ensuite pour ce qui concerne les la
plainte du conseil national de l'ordre
des médecins
celle ci va être instruit par la chambre
disciplinaire et il va y avoir des
choses noires le professeur permanent
pouvoir faire entendre son point de vue
et là par contre ça va durer sur
plusieurs mois ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que je représente nombreux
médecins qui sont qui font l'objet de
plaintes de conseils départementaux à
des médecins devant le champ
disciplinaire et que c'est toujours
toujours la même procédure et le c'est à
dire qu'on va attaquer les médecins pour
des choses qui sont totalement infondées
et on se retrouve ensuite un look femme
devant la chambre disciplinaire mais des
assertions totalement
liste de la kbc conseil d'état l'antenne
est donc mené ou surprend pas du tout
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions thomas ménages rappelle
que êtes avocat du professeur christian
perronne